Росія краде.
І не лише українську сантехніку,
культуру та історію.
З України вона краде найцінніше — українців.
Якби не Росія, слово «депортація»
для нас давно б стало архаїзмом.
Більше ніж 1,6 мільйона українців
депортовані в Росію.
Вони розпорошені по території цієї держави,
по її віддаленим куточкам.
У багатьох із них вилучили документи.
Багато з них пройшли через страшні
російські фільтраційні табори,
де над ними знущалися і залякували.
Це люди, але для Росії — це ресурс.
У 2022 році, після повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії в Україну,
правозахисники зафіксували
масові депортації українців
з Київського Полісся, Слобожанщини,
Донеччини, Приазов’я,
а також Подніпров’я та Запоріжжя.
Ніхто нас не питав.
Ні бажання наше, ні що ми хочемо,
ні як ми хочемо.
Був би в мене вибір, я б ніколи в житті
кордон Росії не перетинала.
Уранці до нас прийшли
російські військові в підвал
і сказали, що якщо ми звідти не вийдемо,
то нас розстріляють.
Російські військові знищують
українські населені пункти
та перешкоджають українцям виїжджати
на територію вільної України.
Також окупанти масово
вивозять українців в Росію,
називаючи це евакуацією,
а депортованих — біженцями.
Тим часом триває евакуація
мирного населення та іноземців
на Київському, Чернігівському,
Сумському, Харківському
та Маріупольському напрямках.
Цими фразами вони намагаються приховати,
що депортації — їхня спланована політика,
успадкована ще від Радянського Союзу.
Союзу, який за 69 років існування
провів близько 110 депортацій,
під час яких примусово переселив
майже шість мільйонів невинних людей.
Тож коли Росія каже:
«Можем павтаріть»,
то повторює вона
саме такі імперські сценарії.
Окупація територій вільних країн,
поневолення й геноцид їхніх народів —
ось що приносить «рускій мір».
За час Другої світової війни
СРСР двічі окуповував країни Балтії.
Обидва рази, щоб усунути опір місцевих,
які прагнули незалежності,
радянська влада проводила
масові депортації.
Перша депортація відбулася
влітку 1940 року.
Радянські війська ввійшли в країни Балтії,
створили там підконтрольні собі уряди
й почали масові чистки,
або фільтрації, як би сказали зараз.
Жителів країн Балтії називали
зрадниками батьківщини,
інкримінували їм так звану
контрреволюційну діяльність
та антирадянську агітацію.
Діти страшенно плакали
і бігли до своїх батьків,
дружини рвалися до чоловіків,
проте солдати всіх відтіснили.
Що саме радянська влада закидала її батькам,
Дайнора Урбоніене не знає досі.
Ймовірно, для підозри достатньо було того,
що обоє були вчителями,
тобто належали до литовської еліти.
Тільки з Литви в 1941 році
до Сибіру депортували
більше ніж 10% її жителів.
Примусово вивезли навіть
президентів Естонії та Латвії,
які пізніше померли в депортації.
У центрі дослідження геноциду
й опору жителів Литви у Вільнюсі
зібрані документи й артефакти тих часів.
Після приходу радянської влади у 1940 році
понад 200 тисяч литовців,
більше ніж 10% населення,
були депортовані до Сибіру.
Загалом, за різними оцінками,
із країн Балтії примусово переселили
від 140 до 350 тисяч людей.
В офіційних документах тих часів
радянська влада називає депортації депортаціями.
І звітує про виконання
оперативного плану
по вилученню антирадянських контингентів.
Майже 50 років потому влада СРСР
сама ж визнає ці депортації незаконними.
Однак у 2020 році
президент Росії Володимир Путін
повернеться до загарбницької риторики.
І для цього ми прагнутимемо
до демілітаризації
та денацифікації України.
У своїй статті до 75-ї річниці перемоги
над нацистською Німеччиною
він називає радянську окупацію
країн Балтії «законним приєднанням».
Але повернімося у XX століття.
Адже згаданим прикладом
депортації «совєтів» [радянська влада],
на жаль, не обмежилися.
Здавалося б, Південна та Північна Кореї
розташовані на тому боці земної кулі,
а ми чомусь живемо тут.
Для мене в дитинстві це було
незрозумілим питанням.
Це питання ніяк не розкривалося.
Лише зараз у наш час
прийшло пояснення населенню,
що корейці були депортовані
з Далекого Сходу
і переселені у Середню Азію.
На початку XX століття корейські селяни,
рятуючись від японської окупації,
масово переселялися
в далекосхідні регіони CРСР.
Проте у вересні 1937 року
радянська влада вирішила,
що такі переселенці мають
підозрілу етнічну приналежність.
Із офіційних пояснень слідує,
що влада не могла відрізнити
корейців від японців.
І щоб запобігти проникненню
японських шпигунів,
примусово переселила 172 тисячі
етнічних корейців
у пустельні, необжиті райони Казахстану
і Центральної Азії.
Коли депортовані прибули до Казахстану,
їх змусили відмовитися від своїх
корейських імен і взяти російські.
Українські німці теж постраждали
від радянських репресій
через етнічне походження.
Нагадаємо, що перші німецькі поселення
на території України
з’явилися ще в XI столітті.
А XVIII столітті було кілька великих хвиль
їх масового переселення на наші терена.
Так значна частина переселенців тікала
від релігійних конфліктів у Німеччині.
До того ж німцям в Україні
надавали земельні наділи,
на 10 років звільняли від податків.
а від військової повинності — назавжди.
Напередодні Другої світової війни в Україні
проживало близько пів мільйона німців.
І в одну мить, після нападу
нацистської Німеччини на СРСР
улітку 1941 року
всі вони стали «ворогами народу».
Радянська влада масово
депортувала українських німців
на північ і далекий схід Союзу.
Частину людей, які перебували на обліку
як «антирадянські елементи», заарештували.
А решту працездатного чоловічого населення
у віці від 16 до 60 років
відправили у трудові табори.
Німцям, які все життя прожили в Україні,
висунули «колективну провину»
тільки через їхнє етнічне походження.
Репресії призвели до того, що до кінця війни
німців в Україні майже не залишилося.
Адміністративну заборону на повернення
їх в Україну зняли аж у 1972 році,
тобто через 27 років
після завершення Другої світової війни.
Саме після примусового переміщення
німецького населення
депортації в Радянському Союзі
набули особливих масштабів.
Параноїдальні підозри
в колаборації населення з ворогами
призвели до того, що в лютому 1944 року
НКВС [Народний комісаріат внутрішніх справ]
за вісім днів насильно переселив
близько 400 тисяч чеченців.
Їх звинуватили в масовій співпраці
з німецькими загарбниками.
Хоча тоді німці окупували лише район
на крайньому північному заході республіки.
Депортовані чеченці були розсіяні по країні
та розміщені у спецпоселеннях,
від яких не можна було відходити
далі ніж на 2–3 км.
Їх зобов'язували працювати
в радгоспах та на заводах,
де платили мізерну зарплату
за важку фізичну працю.
А ще заборонили користуватися
їхньою мовою.
Чеченські діти ходили
в російську початкову школу.
Відразу після депортацій із чеченців
робили зрадників Батьківщини.
У примусовому засланні
цей народ провів 13 років.
У 1957 році радянський уряд
врешті реабілітував чеченців
і дозволив їм повернутися на рідні землі.
«Совєти» [радянська влада] взялися зачищати
від корінних жителів і Кримський півострів.
У квітні 1944 року Лаврентій Берія,
голова НКВС написав
доповідну записку Йосипу Сталіну.
У ній він звинувачував
кримських татар — киримли
у масовому дезертирстві з Червоної армії.
Після цього, з 18 по 21 травня,
кримських татар примусово висилали
до Середньої Азії та на Урал.
Я сам з Криму, кримський татарин.
Батьки мої також з Криму.
Але вони народилися вже в депортації.
Батько народився в Середній Азії.
Я також народився в Середній Азії.
Але мій дідусь, моя бабуся,
всі вони народилися в Криму.
Їх безпідставно звинувачували
в масовому зрадництві
та колабораціонізмі під час німецької окупації.
Радянська влада депортувала
навіть демобілізованих кримських татар
після служби в Червоній армії.
Тобто депортація була одним
із інструментів геноциду.
За офіційними даними, в 1944 році
влада СРСР депортувала
близько 200 тисяч киримли.
Однак, згідно з даними
Національного руху кримських татар,
кількість депортованих удвічі більша.
Від голоду, виснаження та хвороб
за перші три роки після депортації,
за різними оцінками, померли від 20 до 46%
усіх депортованих кримських татар.
На цьому радянська влада не зупинилася
і в 1944 році продовжила масові етнічні чистки,
депортувавши з Криму
ще й болгар, вірменів і греків.
Не минуло і двох місяців після цього,
як очільники СРСР дозволили
переселитися до Криму 51 тисячі людей,
переважно росіянам.
Для проживання їм надавали
порожні оселі кримських татар.
Йосип Сталін прагнув знищити всі сліди
присутності у Криму
корінного народу півострова.
І навіть заборонив етнонім
«кримські татари».
Більш як 40 років у переписах
населення Радянського Союзу
згадки про кримських татар
були заборонені.
А заборона повернення на півострів
діяла для них до листопада 1989 року.
Україна та країни Балтії визнали
депортацію кримських татар
в 1944 році актом геноциду.
У 1990 роках киримли почали
масово повертатися на півострів.
Крим — це Україна!
Ми тут почуваємося вільно.
І це головне.
Тут дихається по-іншому, розумієте?
Але вже у 2014 році,
коли Росія окупувала Крим,
вони знову були вимушені
покинути рідні землі.
А «Меджліс» російська влада офіційно
назвала екстремістською організацією.
І так само, як і в 1944 році, у 2014 році
в Крим почали переселятися росіяни.
Такі дії Радянського Союзу і Росії
як його правонаступниці —
це результат цілеспрямованої політики
примусової асиміляції корінних народів.
Так країна з імперською хворобою
намагається викривити історію
та привласнити собі те,
що їй ніколи не належало.
Перша ціль — це займатися духовністю,
релігійною діяльністю,
щоб ті кримські татари, які вимушено
покинули свою Батьківщину,
зберегли свою ідентичність.
Українці потерпають від депортацій і досі.
Процеси примусового переселення
почалися ще у 2014 році,
коли Росія окупувала Крим
і вдерлася на схід України.
Але після повномасштабного вторгнення
депортації українців стали масовими.
Мільйони українців усупереч своїй волі
опинилися за межами України.
Едуард був у квартирі під час обстрілу.
Він отримав поранення і його евакуювали.
На блокпосту хлопець попросився
на захід України.
Я сказав, що хочу в Запоріжжя.
А російські військові кажуть,
що Запоріжжя більше немає.
Поруч стояв російський солдат,
який сказав, що Київ здався.
Одна з причин цього злочину росіян —
демографічна криза.
Річ у тім, що частка росіян в етнічному складі
населення РФ стрімко зменшується.
Тому влада країни-агресорки хоче збільшити
їх кількість за рахунок етнічних слов’ян.
Особливу увагу приділяють
депортації українських дітей.
Загарбники вивозять із тимчасово
окупованих територій України дітей,
які були сиротами до великої війни
чи втратили батьків уже під час неї.
А дітей, які мають батьків,
вивозять буцімто на відпочинок.
Але там із ними проводять
ідеологічні бесіди
й не завжди після цього
повертають рідним.
Інших забирають з українських сімей
у фільтраційних таборах
і віддають на усиновлення
російським сім'ям.
Дуже інтенсивно бомбили.
Зайшли російські військові, евакуювали.
Мене вивезли на машині,
дітей вивезли на автобусі.
— І незрозуміло що і куди?
— Ні, звісно.
Спочатку була інформація,
що діти просто поїхали відпочивати.
Тут нічого такого немає.
І потім всіх, 31 дитину, повернули, правильно?
Ні. На той момент вони всі
були усиновлені в Москві.
Останнє питання.
Що для Вас було найстрашніше
у цьому досвіді?
Не знати де мої діти.
Влада РФ робить усе,
щоб привласнити собі українських дітей.
У кінці травня 2022 року
Володимир Путін підписав указ,
що спрощує отримання
російського громадянства
для українських дітей.
До цього всиновлювати дітей-іноземців
було заборонено.
Так Росія імітує законність
усиновлення викрадених дітей
та ускладнює їх повернення в Україну.
Ми чекали автобус,
щоб поїхати в табір назад.
Вони мені казали: «До речі, а ти знала,
що ти тепер не українка?
А ти тепер росіянка.
А ти знала, що Маріуполь тепер Росія,
а не Україна?»
Я кажу: «Якщо його можливо захопили —
це не означає, що я росіянка.
Я народилася в Україні, в Маріуполі,
це означає, що я українка».
За процедурою, потенційні всиновлювачі
повинні пройти спеціальне навчання,
де їм, серед іншого, пояснюють тонкощі
ідеологічного виховання українських дітей.
Після всиновлення
прийомним українським дітям
нові батьки мають змінити прізвище,
ім'я та по батькові.
Можновладці Росії відкрито заохочують
такий нібито порятунок дітей.
Яскравий приклад — Марія Львова-Бєлова,
уповноважена при президенті Росії з прав дитини,
очільниця штабу «Детям в руки».
Восени 2022 року вона сама незаконно
всиновила дитину, викрадену з Маріуполя.
Такі дії Росії грубо порушують
Женевську конвенцію
про захист цивільного населення під час війни.
До ідеологічного перевиховання
депортованих українських дітей
підключають і російську православну церкву,
яка просуває міф про «рускій мір»
і єдину православну слов’янську націю.
Практично в кожному регіоні Росії,
куди привозять українців,
є своя єпархія, що опікується
питаннями нібито переселенців.
Депортованих українців
розміщують у монастирях
та інших церковних приміщеннях,
де з ними проводять
виховні просвітницькі бесіди.
Згідно з даними,
які на початку повномасштабної війни
отримали хакери Anonymous та DDoSecrets,
стало відомо, що РПЦ готувалася
до депортацій українців
іще задовго
до широкомасштабного вторгнення.
Міноборони Росії
та інші російські джерела заявляють
про понад 733 тисячі
нібито врятованих дітей
із тимчасово окупованих територій України
за 11 місяців повномасштабної війни.
Їх розселяють по всій Росії,
зокрема й на острові Сахалін.
До нас приїхало 1090 дітей-сиріт
із різних дитячих установ.
Наші громадяни звісно з великим серцем
і вже вишикувались у чергу брати дітей.
Якщо ви дозволите,
я б продовжила цю роботу.
Ми вже сформували реєстр тих,
у кого є документи.
Когось можливо на тимчасове розміщення.
Когось із російським громадянством
можна було б вже влаштовувати.
Чому лише з російським?
З будь-яким громадянством.
Просто є бюрократична тяганина,
яку необхідно тоді буде ліквідувати.
Ви скажіть яка і будемо її ліквідовувати.
Це надзвичайні обставини.
І тут треба думати
не про бюрократичну тяганину,
а про інтереси дітей.
Дані, які періодично озвучує
Марія Львова-Бєлова,
не збігаються з офіційними звітами
її ж штабу «Детям в руки».
Це вказує на навмисне приховування
фактів депортації.
Кількість відомостей про депортованих
українських дітей стрімко зростає.
Але, на жаль, більшість із них
не підкріплені жодними офіційними даними.
Українські правозахисники та правоохоронці
перевіряють інформацію про депортованих.
Наразі спеціалізований ресурс
«Діти війни» інформує,
що встановлено імена близько 15 тисяч
депортованих українських дітей.
Сімнадцятого березня 2023 року міжнародний
кримінальний суд в Гаазі видав ордери
на арешти Володимира Путіна
та Марії Львової-Бєлової
за скоєння воєнного злочину —
депортації дітей із території України в Росію.
Маскуючи депортації українців
під різними словами —
евакуація, порятунок, відпочинок —
Росія продовжує втілювати сплановану
політику знищення українського народу.
Цю державу-терористку потрібно зупинити,
адже сама вона добровільно
не планує зупинятися
у скоєнні злочинів проти людства.